[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we welcome back carson palmer for his uh
weekly visit carson um i was listening
to ryan clark former defensive back on
espn earlier this morning and he said
patrick mahomes
is
too cocky like he's still
trying to he doesn't take the easy stuff
he's still going for those big plays
can you kind of reset your
game plan or mindset as a quarterback
even somebody like patrick mahomes
during the season
oh absolutely i mean that that game was
one of those games where you're on the
sideline and before you know it you're
down 14 nothing
and then you have a three and out and
you go back to the sideline you're
looking at the the play sheets and the
next series and it's 17 nothing and you
feel like that
being down 17 nothing in the first
quarter can sometimes feel like you're
down 35 nothing and you've got to make
something happen fast and that's not the
way kansas city's built kansas city is
not built to get the ball out quick take
what the defense gives you kansas city
has built play action gimmicks
funky little screens and take shots
downfield and
unfortunately for kansas city tennessee
got in a situation where they could just
sit back they could play almost like a
pre-event type defense not let tyreek
hill get over the top and take any big
chunk plays and they were going to force
patrick to take what the defense gives
you and that's just not how they're
built and that's not how he's built his
career up to this point he's taken shots
he hasn't been down 14 17 nothing in the
first half many times so um you know
that that's just not the way he's wired
right now but absolutely he can hit a
reset button he'll go back and he'll sit
down they'll watch film together he'll
say yay or nay on certain throws and
certain decisions from last week and
he's got to continue to progress at the
end of the day patrick mahomes is not a
35 year old vet he is still early on in
his career and has a ton of growing to
do
yeah i wonder about that that it felt
like just keep everything in front of
you contain just you know almost
force them to
be more methodical and not go for those
home run plays and sometimes when you
get it in your mind that tyrek hill
wants to beat you deep travis kelsey
wants to have a big play mahomes wants
to make the big play and the more times
they step on the field knowing they have
to make something happen because that
defense isn't any good it just it ramps
up the pressure but i how surprised are
you people are jumping off the chief's
bandwagon so quickly after seven games
i'm not surprised because the product
isn't very good right now and and at the
end of the day we all need to keep in
mind that tennessee titans are the
perfect team to play kansas city they
can run the ball with derek henry over
and over and over again they can keep
patrick mahomes and tyree kill and
travis kelsey and all those guys sitting
on the sideline waiting for them their
next opportunity so
i'm not off the bandwagon i don't think
the season is over i still think they're
going to compete for that division and
find a way to get in the playoffs and
they'll right the ship because they do
have enough good players if they
continue to stay healthy but at the end
of the day
i mean i can't think of a more
well-designed team to beat them than
than tennessee they play great defense
their coach is the defensive minded
uh really really sharp mike frable
really really sharp defensive mind so he
understands what it means to get the
quarterback off out of rhythm and he
understands what it what it takes to
slow down a tyreek hill and a travis
kelsey so
that was the perfect storm they they
jumped out to an early lead uh the
titans did and that's the way you want
to play kansas city is you keep patrick
mahomes on the sideline and they did
that and that's why they blew them out
what's it like when you have a great
receiver
let's say joe burrow and jamar chase
aaron rodgers and davonte adams like you
get locked in and everybody knows that
you're
you're locked in
how do you
try to tell the defense i'm not always
going to jamar chase or i'm not always
going to devonte adams like
how did rogers in burrow and and
obviously different ages here but
to give that impression of
i i'm going gonna spread the field even
though we know this is your go-to guy
it's tough i mean it's tough on the
quarterback's mentality it's tough for
that receiver because that receiver is
used to getting the ball so often and
can get kind of lackadaisical if we go
through the first quarter then the
second quarter and into the third
quarter without any targets
but you know i i was watching the
arizona game and that's exactly how
kyler murray plays with deandre hopkins
as soon as things get off off timing and
off schedule and he has to move around
the pocket it's almost like he
exclusively looks for deandre hopkins he
just has a certain comfort level he
knows that if he throws it his way and
he misses a little bit deandre will
knock the ball down and not let it get
picked you know those are comfort level
things when you're a quarterback and
you're joe burrow and you feel like you
got to feed jamar chase and get him the
ball early and get him interested in the
game and get get the juices flowing for
him it's really difficult to not get
zoned in and really force him the ball
you've got to take what the defense
gives you and kind of like what i
alluded to earlier in kansas city is
patrick is not used to just taking those
easy chunk those those nice little easy
completions where the ball comes out
they don't do a ton of quick game they
don't throw a bunch of hitches and a
bunch of slants they do a lot of motions
a lot of speed sweeps a lot of play
actions and throw the ball and attack
you downfield so when you get a
quarterback
out of his comfort level and and make
kyler murray move around the pocket
avoid a couple guys he's always
naturally going to look for deandre and
until patrick mahomes really shows us
that he's going to take what the defense
gives them on every play on every drive
through four quarters people are going
to sit back they're going to make him
throw the ball into bad situations
they're gonna make him take off and run
and we saw him do it a couple times
yesterday and he got loose with the ball
you know ended up being a fumble and
going the opposite direction so
there's a certain comfort level that a
lot of these especially young
quarterbacks have with their go-to
targets where when things get wild or
things get off course they're going to
look for those jamar chases and deandre
hopkins
how do you keep everybody happy because
every receiver thinks he's open every
receiver thinks that he could be an
all-pro
there there is no keeping everybody
happy um you know when when you watch
again back to tyler murray kyler
murray's got some vets around him he's
gotten aj green who's kind of been there
done that pro bowls thousand yard
seasons 10 touchdown seasons and now he
just wants to win deandre hopkins
prolific career pro bowl after pro bowl
after pro bowl now he just wants to win
so when you have a young quarterback
with two older experienced vets that get
it and don't need to touch the ball 10
times a game and make sure they get
their thousand-yard seasons those guys
just want to win when you got jamar
chase and some of the guys that t
higgins that joe burrows working with in
cincinnati you know
those guys aren't old vets those guys
are trying to establish themselves those
guys want the ball they can demand the
ball but i think at the end of the day
in cincinnati particularly joe burrow is
a cemented veteran he is a
well-respected well-trusted veteran on
that team even though he's a young guy
so he's he's going to be able to control
the expectations and control the want
and the need for the ball for those
outside players how often would you call
a play just to keep a player happy
it's more it's not so much that it's
more all right i know the easy
completion is throwing the quick out to
the tight end but i think i can get chad
ocho cinco on a big post here or i think
i can throw
jamar chase this deep comeback and hold
the ball for a little bit longer so you
know at the end of the day you got to go
and and i keep saying it you got to take
what the defense has given you
these defenses are too fast they're too
quick there's too many playmakers on the
outside at defensive back you got to
consistently take what the defense gives
you
uh i'm on a town hall
phone call zoom with tom brady later
today
and i get one question
is there is there a question that you
would like answered by tom brady
um
there's not one question there's a
million questions man when i watch him
play at 44 i i don't get it how does he
practice on wednesday i think that's
that's the question does he really
practice on wednesday are they fudging
the injury report or at 44 after a
sunday game 72 hours later is he
finishing a practice on wednesday and
thursday and what to what extent is he
practicing on wednesday thursday is he
just out there with shoulder pads and a
helmet and putting a mouthpiece in or is
he literally going through
bag work and jump rope and moving around
the pocket and throwing the ball to
receivers yeah but he doesn't get hit on
sunday carson
he got hit once on sunday by the bears
that that one hit at 44 can take
it can take an entire week to wear that
sword to stop i just want to know is he
really doing it or are they fudging that
injury report
600 career touchdown passes
that's mind-boggling
it's it's mind-boggling
there's no doubt about it i mean what
he's doing at
you know at the end of the day there's a
reason he plays for the tampa bay
buccaneers he could have gone pretty
much anywhere he wanted he knew at 44.
he needed to be able to throw a quick
slam to chris godwin that can go to the
house or throw you know a quick hitch to
mike evans and he can break a tackle and
go for 60. he needed that kind of
playmaking ability and speed
antonio brown the the two running backs
they have in the backfield with leonard
fournette leading the way i mean he
needed that kind of talent and that kind
of ability around him because he you saw
it in his last two or three years in in
uh in new england i mean julian
edelman's a great player but he's not a
game breaking player he can't blow a
game open he's sitting on a on a roster
with two or three players that can
absolutely blow a game open
we're talking to carson palmer former
nfl quarterback uh did the heisman
trophy show up
that's a good question i i have not seen
it yet but i i mean fritz is there
anybody better on the princess
is there anybody better
yeah oh yeah there's tons of people
better than fritzy let's see if you get
it carson wait why why are you giving
fritzy credit
because fritzy's the man he does all
your dirty work
he's on top of it are you on top of this
do you know when the the carson's uh
heisman shows up if it hasn't arrived it
should be there any day
that means he doesn't know a damn thing
we have we have ways to track the very
special idea we're not gonna make we're
gonna make sure it doesn't get lost i
just want to make sure because that
that's a that's a
bank vault that we put it in now what
are you gonna do
are you gonna put that in the hall of
fame
so
fritzy being the amazing human being
that he is sent it to the hall of fame
because the hall of fame is on december
7th or december 11th so when i get there
and we have the the ceremony
the
hall of fame asked for some memorabilia
trophies kind of different stuff from
from my career and so they're going to
set it up shop they're going to have a
locker on display and the heisman will
be in there uh-huh
well it's all do all due to fritz no no
well let's make sure it gets there
though carson because if it doesn't then
it's on fritzy right
i trust fritz
yeah
tom brady wouldn't trust fritzy and by
the way fritzy is a bronco fan so
can you really trust
a bronco fan
it's been a long season i mean they won
three games and they might only win
three games unfortunately fritzy could
you be the best quarterback on the
broncos roster if you uh went there now
for like six plays okay maybe five
players i've got five plays and i'm out
any issues with your undefeated
cardinals
uh
injuries obviously when you look at that
team and you look at some of the i mean
they have one of the best defensive
lines in the league
they're stout they can stop the run they
got two edge rushers with marcus golden
they got chandler jones
i like the way they're built from top to
bottom if if they can stay healthy i
don't know anybody that can play with
them now if they lose a chandler or they
lose the deandre hopkins
things could go south real quick but the
way that team is built there are some
stars at key positions if they stay
healthy i don't know that anybody can
beat them that weather last night in san
francisco
was
that was brutal
did you ever
but it is it wind or rain that that's
the worst
wind 100 i'd rather play in snow sleet
rain
uh
lightning i'd rather take my take my
chances i'm not probably not the tallest
guy in the field
but wind changes everything because once
you get inside these stadiums there's
always an entry point for where the wind
comes in there's very few
stadiums built like the rose bowl where
it's just a perfect bull now there's
ends that are open in one way or another
and when that wind comes in that stadium
and it starts swirling you can feel like
at the 20-yard line when you take a snap
the wind's in your face but if you're
throwing a deep ball and the ball goes
up over the 30 and past the 40-yard line
that wind direction totally changes in
the stadium so it can be a crapshoot
especially if you're on the road when
you're at home you know a little bit
more about different wind directions uh
in your own stadium but when you're on
the road it's a crap shoot unless you
know that stadium like tom brady does
just about every stadium in the league
you know it's it's one of those things
that
it can kill a game plan you can have
four or five deep shots you really like
versus defense but if it's a windy weird
day like that it can take four or five
deep shots out of the game playing
because you just can't trust the wind
and putting a lot of touch and putting
air underneath the ball what was the
worst weather you ever played in
i played a game in miami in 2016-2017
and when we landed in florida we knew
there was there was a storm coming
and it was just one of those weird games
every time we had the ball on offense a
downpour ensued and i'm talking like
like like a movie set
rainstorm you know you watch a movie
sometimes you're like there's i've never
seen it rain like that and it's this
real romantic you know scene where these
two characters are about to kiss and
it's just like somebody's dumping a
picture of just relentless water it was
one of those weird games the storm
system came in over over uh planet
hollywood stadium and just absolutely
dumped i think there was like six or ten
fumbles in the game nobody could hold on
to the ball it was one of those days
uh did you have any bets with notre dame
friends with usc notre dame this past
weekend
uh no but i bet notre dame to cover and
won i just figured they were gonna blow
him out and i was right
wow
so you bet against usc
yeah i mean when it comes to now now
with all this online legal betting when
it comes to when it comes down to the
money you gotta go with where you think
you're gonna win not who you want
that's why you still have all your money
yeah you gotta hold on to it make some
more
uh hey great to talk to you are you
being um included in conversations uh as
a sounding board for who should be usc's
next head coach
i've been talking to um a bunch of folks
and and giving input here and there and
um
yeah i've been as as ball as involved as
they'll let me be
okay do you want to is james franklin
the front runner as i've reported
uh i i think i think there's a lot of
front runners right now and that's why i
like where we're sitting you know we we
had the first hot seat open up you can't
have a lot of front runners carson you
can have a front runner
you've got penn state you've got iowa
state you've got cincinnati you've got a
wild card like uh
mike tomlin that if mike tomlin wants
out and and i think
you know at the end of the day there is
not a direct that's the guy everybody's
pointing their fingers at there's a
there's a lot of great options has has
mike tomlin hypothetically been
discussed
uh
i i'm sure he has i think i think
anybody is a potential candidate right
now and that's what's so great about the
job is it can lure an nfl guy in that's
tired of their current situation and
worried about is ben
roethlisberger gone is he done who are
we going to draft do i have does mike
tomlin have to start over with a
first-round young rookie quarterback you
know everybody's on the table being that
that job is so big and so coveted um you
know i think i think there's a bunch of
people that that are in the discussion
and once we get to week 16 17 of the nfl
season and the college football season
is over we'll have a direct front runner
wow okay
that's pretty spicy with mike tomlin
there
i like it is that the first you've heard
of that yeah
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
i uh
i think it's the first a lot of people
probably heard about that okay
i think he's a great option i i i know
that's nice
nine years that'd be great i mean you
get mike tomlin at usc okay better job
and now take off your your trojan hat
um
usc or lsu
oh i don't think it's even close i think
lsu is a great job no doubt about it but
there's only
one usc there's only one school that has
the tradition the history the first
round draft picks the all-american uh
playing in the coliseum one of the most
uh nostalgic from the olympics the super
bowls you name it um
in los angeles
i mean i i i think it's the best job i
think it's also when you compare the
pac-12 to the sec there's no doubt
there's no comparison from a talent
level
between each school and both of those
conferences
but the easiest routes the national
championship is not through the sec the
easiest route to win a national
championship which if you take that job
at usc the bar was set extremely high
with pete carroll and his success so you
will only be judged on national
championships at usc and right now there
is a much easier route to playing in the
national championship through the
playoffs in the pac-12 than there is in
the sec
he's uh
college football insider carson palmer
got a you know usc booster we got to
change your title it's not former nfl
quarterback heisman trophy winner you're
now an insider
i'm a man of many hats dan yes you are
but you only have one on
only one on today you'll see me in a new
one next week all right buddy thank you
carson great to talk to you thank you
that's carson palmer his weekly
appearance
brought to you by our good partner level
select cbd looking for next level relief
visit levelselectcbd.com